[Music]
is
God
God legislation comes from yeah so for
example we have the Quran which comes
from Allah subhana tala which was
delivered to us by the prophet peace be
upon him as well as the Hadith as you
would know we we don't just take Quran
and from that we derive the legislations
and legal rulings that we are to take
from in terms of guiding Our
Lives okay awesome and so uh you also
said worship meaning he is the only one
that is worthy of worship right nothing
else understand what worship
is yes I do okay can you can you give
a I'm sorry can you give a brief
understanding of what the Islamic
concept of worship is oh the Islamic oh
you just ask me what worship is um if
you want to I don't want to misrepresent
you if you can give me the so we direct
all of our actions such as things that
you were just asking about right now
worship lordship and so on and so forth
all of these things are solely directed
towards Allah subhana tala so though we
get our legislation and rulings and so
on and so forth from the prophet
Muhammad it's not to say that we are
worshiping him by means of obeying him
right because the obeying part is not
the part in which we direct his uh we
don't direct the actions that we do
towards the prophet peace be upon him we
directing towards God so got it so who
do you fully submit to when it comes to
by means of directing our actions
towards him and him alone do you fully
submit to Muhammad as well right so we
obey Muhammad peace be upon Him
submitting to him in the sense where if
we were to direct our actions of worship
towards him no we don't do that no
that's not what I ask I ask do you
simply do you fully submit I clarified
that's why I made it specific right in
terms of obeying him we do follow the
commands in which he was given by God to
give to us however we do not direct
these commands towards him we only
direct them towards God are is there
ever commands that he may give that are
not direct Revelation from God no all
commands that come from the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him are direct
Revelation from God okay and so the Ted
of his uh of his attributes means that
he is the only one that possesses these
attributes right he's the only one that
possesses them in the likeness in which
they uh they occur so for example uh
existence in an itself you and I may
exist but we do not exist in the same
way in which God does he exists
independently and he is only dependent
upon himself so he's the he's the only
self-sufficient one exactly is uh okay
so he's the only self-sufficient one um
he's the only one who's all powerful the
most merciful and things of this nature
that all only belongs to him in those
ways right exactly those attributes okay
um is he is is there anything that's
uncreated that's not Allah La uncreated
that's not Allah La what do you mean is
there anything in existence that is also
uncreated or is Allah the only one who
was
uncreated so if you mean by uncreated do
you mean necessary or do you mean
literally independent I mean that it's
never had uh it's never had a point
where it came into
existence okay so to my knowledge no
okay so um the attributes of Allah
[Music]
would you say that they are distinct
from Allah or are they one with you know
are they Allah right so they are
distinctions and that does not mean that
they are separate to him right so when
we say that the attributes are a
distinction of Allah subhana tala this
refers to the fact that they are a
counter indep counter independent with
his Essence do you understand counter
independent with his Essence what does
that mean sorry counter dependent
counter dependent my B what does that
mean okay so a counter dependency just
simply means means that the essence and
the attributes coexist with each other
in order for Allah subhana tala to be
who he is he he cannot exist with one
without the other for example we can't
say that an Essence can exist without an
attribute and we can't say that an
attributes can exist without an Essence
right so the two of them are necessary
in order for Allah to exist he can't
exist without either one just like
anything else that exists right for
example if I was to say um this like a
rock exists okay and uh that rock has
absolutely no properties well that's not
really something that we could say that
exists right properties are things that
are used to define anything in
particular that exists okay uh can Allah
exist without his
speech once again I just said that
attributes cannot exist ex without the
uh the essence so no so Allah cannot
exist without his speech without his
attribute of being able to speak yeah he
can't exist without it okay right and so
um uh is the Quran Allah's
speech is the Quran Allah's speech yeah
it's part of the speech it's not the
entirety of the attribute of speech of
Allah okay so it's part of the attribute
of his speech is the Quran is the Quran
created no the Quran is
uncreated the Quran is uncreated the
Quran is uncreated understand what
uncreated and created means so when we
say that the attributes and the things
the actions that come from Allah subh
are created we're talking about the
existence of these particular things in
general so anything any action in which
God does they are not dependent upon
anything other than himself when we say
words like contingent dependent
independent so on and so forth we're
just simply meaning that they do not
depend on anything else to exist other
than the individual himself which would
be God in this case right he doesn't
depend on for example you or I to exist
in order for his attribute of speech or
the result of the attribute of speech to
exist okay
so uh the Quran has never come into
create uh into existence as it's always
existed correct what does that mean like
are you saying that the Quran didn't
come into for example our world or are
you no no no I mean like there was there
was never a point where the Quran did
not exist okay so in terms of his
knowledge no it's always existed and in
terms spech in ter I'm getting there
relax and by the way I didn't know that
this was a Q&A session but go through it
we're just talking we're just talking
about yeah yeah yeah no problem so in
terms of the Quran this is something
that has always existed within the
knowledge of Allah T in terms of the
attribute of speech obviously it's
something that was brought forward
towards his Creation in order for us to
also be able to acknowledge it so
respectfully that's not what I'm asking
so uh is is Allah's knowledge uh
distinct from his speech is Allah's
knowledge ex distinct from a speech yeah
sure but in terms of in terms of let me
finish let me finish
okay so in terms of specific attributes
of Allah such as speech such as
knowledge so on and so forth there are
particular attributes that do come into
play together for example his speech and
his knowledge without his knowledge
there would be no coherent speech right
all of them have to come together in
order to formulate particular things
which Allah does with intention right no
worries no worries but as soon as you uh
I'm glad though that you acknowledge
that there is a distinction between
Allah's speech and Allah's knowledge
they're not the same thing so if they're
not the same thing and we can get past
that which is good so the Quran you said
is part of Allah's speech right all
right it's yeah it's from his speech we
wouldn't say necessarily par go ahead if
I said well that's what you said I'm
going with you you said part of
speech I took it back hold on I
retracted it if I said speech I
specifically said I retracted it go
ahead don't build off of a false
argument oh yeah I don't want to I I
want to make sure we represent you
correctly so I I'll ask you again is the
Quran Allah's speech yeah it's from his
speech I didn't say it is his speech is
the Quran Allah speech yeah it's part of
the speech yeah it's part of the speech
yeah it's part of the speech um is it
his speech or not I just said it's it is
not the entirety of Allah speech so it's
it's part of his speech never said part
I'm asking I said no so okay so if it's
not part of his speech then it is his
speech right so the real understanding
in terms of why we don't say part is
because specifically when you say part
it means that there's a limit to
something or that it is a chunk of it
and so on and so forth right we're not
to say that there's we're not to say
that there's a limit to Allah speech
first and foremost because it's
something we continue on and on right so
it's not something that ends we would
say that it's from the speech from the
knowledge of God okay again so if it's
from his speech the Quran is from his
speech then it is his speech right now
when you say when you say when you say
wait hold on let me just let me just let
me just preface it I'm sorry I'm sorry
let me just preface it spee wait atachi
please please I listen to you I listen
to you atachi hold on it's like hold on
no no because you're cutting me off in
the middle I don't mean I I'm sorry I I
know let me just let me finish please
respectfully false Point go ahead well
yeah I'm not building off a false point
I'm just building off what you said when
you say because you said this that the
Quran is not the entirety of Allah's
speech that literally means that the spe
the Quran then is part or a chunk of
Allah's speech by
default yeah so we're not gonna read we
don't have to deflect or desist towards
the way that you want to clarify a
particular point right so if I say it's
from it then I would I would ask you to
acknowledge the terminology that I use I
I am that's why I'm asking you when I
I said from so okay I'll ask again when
you when you said uh that the Quran is
not entirely Allah's speech
right that's why I said it's from it for
the fifth time right so when you say
that it's not entirely Allah's speech
that means it is some of Allah's speech
correct it is from speech I never said
it's some of it I never said it's a
chunk of it that's clearly words that I
did not use so keep asking the same
question 10 times or move on to the next
one no no no Itachi here's the here's
the thing and I think that this is where
you kind of got yourself in trouble is
um with your terminology your
terminology by using words like entirely
automatically by default mean that okay
it is some of or a part of when you say
entire it's not in it's it's it's not
the entirety of his speech that means it
is some of his speech or of his speech
sure sure let's go with that let's go
with that go ahead let's go with that go
ahead okay thank you so the Quran is
part of Allah's speech so Allah's speech
then is has components to it it can be
divided in a
way okay the speech the attribute of
speech or are you talking about the
contents Allah speech we're about Allah
speech speech no the content
sure okay spee the speech in and of
itself is an attribute you understand
that right sure sure when you say
something for example you have the
ability to do that right that's not to
say that the attribute in and of itself
is something that can be broken up the
content sure I would agree with you okay
so does the speech by necessity contain
content within
it the speech by necessary no the
attribute in and of itself is something
that you have the ability to do the
speech the content that comes afterwards
right that's something different okay so
when you said because you you affirmed
earlier that the Quran was was is
uncreated right it's not created there's
not a time where it came into existence
right yeah and what did I say uncreated
means so so well well that's why I'm try
say that this was gonna be a back
forward so can you answer what I said
when well yes that's well I I I actually
clarified what I meant by uncreated and
you said yes if I'm not mistaken what
did I say it means so what I said that
it means and you agreed is that it
doesn't there's not been a point in time
that it came into existence okay and
specifically what specifically what
specifically the speech specifically
that it does not depend upon anybody
else in order for it to exist other than
the source itself right I'm not asking
about dependenc gave you I gave you the
understanding in terms of what we say
when we mean things like contingent when
we mean counter dependency and so on and
so forth right these things are all only
and solely dependent upon the
self-existent one which is God which is
Allah I'm not I'm not I'm not asking
about dependency I'm not asking about
what it depends on its uh I'm just
clarifying make sure that you don't end
up strong at okay good I'm not so so
please clarify what I ask not what I'm
not asking okay so do we agree then that
the
Quran is uncreated in the sense that it
has
never had a point in time that it came
into
existence I I can't hear you if you're
off the off the screen getting help or
something you want to keep going sure go
ahead okay so in terms of what I was
saying in terms of there being a
distinction between the speech and the
content of the speech what I mean by
that is the fact that the attribute
itself which is from the right because
it's an action the action itself is
something which is uncreated and the
speech itself is all the sorry the
content of the speech itself is also
uncreated now when we say that the the
content can be broken up for example
when I say bis right that's one of the
words of Allah subhana T from the Quran
right or from the uncreated speech that
he has but this is not to say that the
speech itself the attributes can be
broken
up I can't see part of his attributes as
such and such okay so um the words what
you said the speech is an action right
yes the attribute of speech is an action
and so the AC of speech is doing
what okay the action of speech is
something that coincides in regards to
Allah's Essence and so on and so forth
and it allows what is it what is this
what is is the action what is the action
I'm literally getting there right so the
action specifically allows for Allah
subh to communicate in any particular
way in which he
feels okay so speech by definition is
communication by by necessity right sure
in terms of what in in terms of going
from giving point a to an individual who
is other than him oh no not NE not
necessarily just it's communication he's
this this this attribute of speech no
the attributes in and of itself I would
disagree with you I disagree with you so
the attribute in and of itself is not
something that necessitates another
individual in order for you to be able
to communicate right you could have an
attribute and not necessarily be uh
utilizing the attributes for
example okay so okay good so if if the
attribute is there right because you
said speech is an action you said it's
an action okay so this is something that
is eternal that's uncreated that's
always been it's not been a time where
it's not happening has Allah always been
doing the action of of speech okay so
again I like I literally just said and
by the way this is the position that I
hold to at the very least right in terms
of what I just said it does not
necessitate the idea that you have to
continuously be doing something in order
for you to be inherently having a
particular attribute so I would I would
disagree with that but I'm I'm sorry
though but as soon as you said that
speech is an action the attribute of
speech is an action then you have
already conceded that speech is
something that you're always doing it's
an action you not it's not just
something where where where's the
connection to that can you please like
break it down a bit sure what an action
an action is something you do okay
action is something you do I agree
hold on hold on I never said that you
have to continu be doing the action in
it to be considered uncreated regards to
Allah that's not something me okay okay
so if speech by by default is an action
according to you is an action it's
something that Allah is doing forever
always from eternity's past you can't
say that you can't say
that well you're saying No this is
sorryi hold on this is this is me
analyzing what you said and coming to
his right conclusion now if you're
trying to say now that well no you know
his his attribute of speech isn't
something that he always does it's just
something he possesses then you're not
saying then that speech is the action is
an action it's just some type of
attribute that he has but not an action
you talking about okay so when we say
action what do we mean by that it's
something that he particularly does
correct correct okay beautiful so from
that particular action which he does is
it necessitated that he has to
continuously be doing that action in
order for that's that's my question to
you okay no I I literally just answered
you prior to that that it's not the case
that you always have to be doing okay
beautiful so so there's a point in time
listen listen can I finish an answer no
go ahead I I'm just I'm chilling stop
interrupting I'm not hey we we
interjecting each other you no I'm I'm
not interjecting you the only time I
interject is when you interrupt me no
need to be feisty go ahead if you go
ahead no problem so in terms of the
action once again it does not have to be
something that's continuously utilized
in order for it to be considered
uncreated in order for it to be
considered an attribute and so on and so
forth go ahead that's all I had to
say all right so then that means so that
means wait wait you just said you
finished go ahead go ahead go ahead all
right beautiful masua so if you just
said that um
that is it doesn't necessitate that he's
always doing this action right then
there's a point in time where he does
the action of speech then right okay so
going back to the definition I said of
uncreated since you clearly missed it
can you please go back to what I said
uncreated refers to no I can't because
that's not what because you don't
remember making this bogus point right
now yeah no I'm not though because I'm
talking about if you actually listen to
what I you're interrup me now you're
interrup me now you're interrup to me
now yeah I you you stopped actually it
was
my go back to it you said I didn't stop
I didn't stop actually you did I asked
you to go back to the word so I when you
said when you said talking about
uncreated talking about dependability
and uh it doesn't depend on uh uh uh any
it depends on Allah for for you know y y
y that's not what I asked uncreated
meaning there hasn't been a time where
this thing
has come into being that's what that's
what uncreated means oh my God so are we
on the same page uncreated once again
does not refer to only what you're
talking about right now I already
multiple times is there a is there a
sense of uncreate of something being
uncreated that at at some point in time
came into
existence okay so in terms of uncreated
the way that I defined it for you and
the way that you're clearly trying to
avoid right now is specifically the fact
that it's unsourced from anything other
than God and it is solely dependent upon
his existence in terms of that that's
what we mean when we say that it's
uncreated in terms of it being a
attribute which we understand the fact
that it can occur in any particular
Moment In Time a f attribute occurs at a
particular period where Allah subh T
reveals something this is not to say
that the Quran is UN is sorry is created
simply because it's also something that
is part of other attributes as well
right for examp it is something that
comes from his knowledge it is something
that comes from his speech it's
something that comes from his wisdom and
so on and so forth each of these has
particular manners in which it functions
with the Quran thank you uh do you as a
human being rely on and depend on Allah
for your
existence can you repeat that do you as
a human being rely on Allah solely for
your
existence do I yes I I Rely Upon Allah
for my existence are you
uncreated am I uncreated no I'm not
uncreated thank you thank you so much so
we just got rid of we just got rid of of
the fluff of by uncreated meaning
something that solely depends on Allah
for its existence or for its state of
being that's out the window so we're
talking about uncreated notreated Excuse
excuse me excuse me let me finish please
let me finish okay go ahead promise I
promise you I'm G listen I promise so we
get that out the way we see that things
that depend solely on Allah's on Allah
for their EX for its existence right
does not mean that it's uncreated we
know that we're talking about something
that has either come into being or has
always existed without coming into being
without having a beginning starting
point that's what we're talking about so
please don't go on anything else this is
what we're talking about but when the
term unre created is the Quran
uncreated in the sense that it has never
had a time where it came into
being yes it is so thank specifically
okay can I finish yeah of course I say
thank you go ahead okay without the
adlibs please than no no with the adbs
you need the adbs thank you okay so you
could keep going with the adbs or we
could get central to moderate it which
by the way you did good we having a good
conversation why are you so sens right
right so so don't do the abbs I'm just
asking you for some decent respect right
no I'm a do the I it's part of my
personality all right so you won't be
respectful I'm respecting you go ahead
I'm listening yeah so when it comes to
the speech of Allah when it comes to the
Quran again it is uncreated by way of
the fact that it comes from no one other
than God and the fact that it is
something that has always existed with
his knowledge with his wisdom and so on
and so forth when it comes to a fairy
attribute it is something that is used
by Allah subhana T in order to
communicate it to us this is not to say
that it's cre created it's not to say
that this attribute of speech is created
and so on and so forth like once again
and by the way I I would just want to
clarify one thing that you were talking
about as well when it comes to the
attributes and the unification of them
right this is not to say that anything
with regards to them is by default
deferred from Allah subhana tala and the
fact that it's like for example what you
were trying to compare it to when it
comes to me and so on and so forth right
if I exist that's not to say that I
exist just because Allah because I exist
created and so on and so forth right I
exist by way of for example the fact
that Allah has given life to me and so
on and so forth the way in which Allah's
attributes exist is not the same way
okay so we were just respect did you did
you okay so uh the reason why I brought
you up is because you were saying that
by you was giving your definition and
meaning of uncreated to to mean that
something that the Quran is uncreated in
the sense that uh it solely depends on
Allah for its existence it's not
Dependable on anything outs side of
Allah for its existence that's why I
went to you and and and showed you the
fallacy in that type of definition
because that would mean then you're
uncreated though uh because you rely
solely on Allah for your existence but
you were able to recognize that wait no
I am created so therefore that
definition doesn't work okay now
when resp
resp no I let you go on for a minute I
let you go on for so you don't want me
to respond to what just you can respond
in a second okay so go ahead spit fire
points go ahead go ahead well I'm not
trying to you spit fire points I mean I
mean I'm asking you if I can reply to a
point and then you want to spit the
answer is no answer so go ahead spit
fire points go ahead all right
Mas now you're saying that well the
attribute is U uh uh is is uncreated
also in the sense that it uh you know it
exists always within Allah's knowledge
the Quran is is uncreated in the way
that it existed always in Allah's
knowledge I'm going to ask you now have
you always existed in Allah's knowledge
okay so did I say it solely exists only
in Allah's knowledge no you didn't that
was part of
itse so what else did I say specifically
inad of instead of straw mening what
else did I say I didn't Straw Men you
okay so I'm asking you what else did I
say I told you what you just said so can
you answer so is it just the knowledge
no no no but that's what I'm so what
else was it so you said it depends
solely on Allah for its existence and it
exists uh always in Allah's knowledge as
well as as well as what what
else yo guys we're we're kind of going
uh in circles no this is good right now
but it's kind of like going it's
repetitive if you're not understanding
her do you want me to bring someone up
that can no she's doing good Sor I'm not
talking to nobody else but either you or
her okay okay so from the knowledge
again there is other things that come
into play with it can you please repeat
what the other things that came into
play were that I said no no no no no no
no no I'm asking you because it was not
the only one that I said and the answer
is no atachi I asked you something very
simple have you always existed have you
always existed in Allah's knowledge okay
is that the only thing that I said in
which it comes to the
Quran talk when it comes to uncreated
difference the difference between the
Quran and myself is that obviously there
are other things that come into play
what were the other things that I said
hold okay I I'll I'll name what I
remember you saying okay and then
hopefully you can answer you said in
relating to the quran's uncreated that
it's uncreated in the sense that it's
always been in Allah's knowledge and it
solely depends on Allah for its
existence is not dependent on something
else for its existence but solely on
Allah's Essence that's what you said is
there did I miss
something yes you absolutely did because
that's not the only attribute I
mentioned what other attributes well
well tell me so that way I can continue
to ask you the question maybe you can
finally answer okay so the main one
being right the main one being is the
one that you're asking about in regards
to his speech the one about his
knowledge the one about his wisdom and
so on and so forth so can you please
tell me how I applied each of them to
the speech of Allah wait wait wait no
specifically the not about that it's
it's it's it's this actually it is this
is is the Quran is the Quran Allah want
to answer to it is the Quran Allah's
knowledge okay so I asked you specific
because I did not say that the Quran is
only his knowledge right once so you're
saying the Quran is a multitude of
Allah's attributes I'm asking you to
tell me which other attributes that I
apply it to and which one no no if you
if you apply other attributes to it I'm
I'm simply asking you this question okay
is the Quran a multitude of Allah's
attributes okay so when you say
multitude do you mean that it's coming
into play with other attributes or are
you saying that it occurs multiple
different times in different ways no so
I'm asking the Quran itself the Quran
itself is it because I know that it's
Allah's speech I know it's cam Allah I'm
asking is it also knowledge of Allah is
it also is it also his knowledge is it
also his other you know other things
okay so we would not okay so the way
that you're wording that is incorrect
right we would not say that it's
identical to the knowledge we would not
say it's identical to the cam and so on
and so forth right we would say that
these are things that contribute to the
Quran in and of itself right the Quran
is from the knowledge of Allah the Quran
is from the speech of Allah the Quran is
from the wisdom of Allah not identical
to each of the attributes do you
understand got it so the Quran is not
Kalam Allah it has some ofam in it okay
it Isam is speech for the people
listening specifically from the of Allah
I did not say some I did not say part so
once again terminology otherwise
otherwise you could just start referring
to Scholars and bringing their quotes up
if you think I'm misquoting something by
the way okay so let's let's just be
clear okay because I'm G ask you this
very straightforward question once one
more time so I can move on to the next
question has there ever been a time
where the Quran where the
Quran came into existence yes or no so
once again no I've answered it five
times do you have a new question yeah I
do
now is the Quran distinct from Allah
okay so the Quran is from the of Allah
subh which is distinct from him not
separate to him it's something which is
codependent or if you want to say
counter dependent upon the essence and
the existence of Allah subhana tala one
cannot exist without the other beautiful
okay
um okay good now on the day of
Resurrection really quick can you just
repeat what I just said no I won't okay
do you even understand on the day of
Resurrection on the day of Resurrection
uh will the Quran intercede on your
behalf yeah the Quran will intercede on
my behalf My fasting if you want to
finish quoting the Hadith My fasting
will intercede on my behalf and so on
and so forth what does it mean to
intercede okay so the intercession is by
way in this particular Hadith the way
the understanding of the Sal
particularly puts it for this Hadith is
the fact that these things the actions
that we've done and so on and so forth
are things that are going to come in in
terms of the fact that we did either we
did these actions or we did not do these
actions that's all it is it's not hold
on what does it what does it mean to
intercede let me finish let me finish
okay so intercession again in this
particular Hadith is the fact that our
actions are going to testify for us on
our behalf that's why fasting is
mentioned in the Hadith that's why Quran
is mentioned in the Hadith by means of
the fact that you are reciting it right
and the fasting by means of the way that
you are actually doing the particular
fasting and so on and so forth says
that's not what the Hadith says that's
literally I could pull up quotes from
the set up if you want let's let's have
to do with yeah exactly exactly what
does it have to
do quote you hold on I can quote you the
interpretation wait wait it was my to
talk it was the first question if I
follow the S if I pull up quotes for you
right now you're going to get busted
well thank you so so now it's so now
it's my turn to talk right okay go ahead
okay so so when you say uh you say that
these actions will testify on your
behalf testify to Allah right yeah
okay so they'll be testifying to Allah
on your behalf including the Quran the
Quran itself according to the Hadith
will intercede will testify on that day
on your behalf and how exactly did I say
he was going to do that I I well you're
you're saying that it's the action of
you reciting it and things of this
nature that's your understanding right
beautiful go ahead go ahead yeah very
good the Quran doesn't the Hadith
doesn't say that the Hadith doesn't say
that that that the way that you recite
it and all that that that will be what
uh what comes and intercedes on you or
speaks for you the Hadith says that the
Quran itself will intercede for you talk
back to Allah and say Allah this person
recited me in this part of the night
this person recited me in this this such
and such verses so the Quran itself is
going to speak the speech of Allah or
not the some of the speech of Allah that
is uncreated that has always existed
that's not Allah but distinct from Allah
is going to on the day of judgment speak
and defend you to Allah in which it's
not separated from I want to know what
is your problem with the Trinity if this
is your belief okay so first and
foremost this has nothing to do with the
Trinity if you want to debate the
Trinity formally about The Logical
coherency of it I already offered you a
debate to which you rejected yesterday
right so we could do that we could set
that up no problem but in terms of this
Hadith again if you want I will pull up
quotes for you because you ask me me
about my position in the beginning
regarding the salaf to which I told you
I'm a salafi right I take from the salaf
if you want their opinion on this Hadith
where it affirms exactly what I said I
will give that to you so which one would
you like would you like to debate The
Logical coherency of the Trinity or
would you like to actually continue a
discussion abouted yeah we're actually
talking about The Logical coherence of
Ted right right now and what I'm showing
you is waiting for the and what I'm and
what I'm showing you hold on I just let
you finish what I'm showing you is that
according to Ted
that's logically incoherent because
you're saying that only Allah has these
attributes of being you know infinite
self-sufficient Eternal uncreated and
things of this nature that these things
are that he's absolutely singular in his
Essence he's absolutely singular in his
Essence yet you have another thing that
is not separate from Allah but distinct
from him who that is also uncreated
because it shares in the essence of
Allah uh and will defend and speak to
you speak for you excuse me on your
behalf back to Allah the speech of Allah
is going to speak back to Allah so it's
going to have some type of personhood or
Consciousness at least in this moment
speak back to Allah right here in this p
in in this in this time you have a
plurality of personhood or Consciousness
within Allah's essence or you just need
to say that you have something else
that's uncreated that's not Allah
plurality can can okay can you expand on
the plurality part go ahead yeah the uh
the expansion is is that you have
Allah's speech or word that now develops
some type of cognitive ability that's
able to speak and have knowledge and
defend uh you as a Believer knows what
you did and able to speak on your behalf
and defend uh your uh you uh to Allah be
able to speak to Allah that's personhood
that's cognitive ability also though the
Quran as you said is not separate from
Allah so it's within Allah it's cu it's
it's some of his it's from his speech so
it's from the essence of Allah So within
Allah's own Essence now you have a
plurality of persons it would it would
seem persons yes
cognitive once again I will offer you a
debate on regards to the Trinity right
but nobody I I mean you could quote me
any setup or any even like contemporary
scholar in terms of uh somebody using
the word persons but I mean you did say
you want to do an internal critique of
what is right or if you want to do an
external one by all means but be sure
that you know what words that you're
using right so first and foremost a
plurality would refer to the fact that
an attribute in specific occurs two
times in Allah's Essence right so the
attributes in and of itself does the
attribute of speech occur two times in
Allah no it doesn't right there's only
one attribute of speech we all
understand what the word speech means so
on and so forth right there's only one
attribute of knowledge and likewise for
all
of attribute of knowledge and likewise
for all of the Quran once again do do
you want me to quote you people from the
Sala because you asked me my position so
once again I'm asking you do you want me
to quote you the people from the Sala
who tell you that this is the
understanding of the Hadith or do you
want to keep expanding upon something
that you have no knowledge about no no
no it's not that uh I don't want you to
quote uh what your people say I I know
what some of you guys say and the
understanding how you guys try to
interpret this Hadith my thing is
actually going I'm critiquing your
understanding and showing you how your
understanding is a cop
uh and going away from what the Hadith
actually says the Hadith doesn't say
anything about oh well it's um you know
it's in these particular actions it's
the reason that you uh uh recited the
Quran and you believed in it and rece
and recited it that the fact that you
did that will uh be you know be be extra
points for you on the day of
Resurrection no the the Hadith says that
the Quran itself the Quran itself will
intercede for you will speak to Allah
for you not just that but the Quran also
will have two chapters two chapters that
will that will split off and come as
flocks of birds right or clouds it says
either birds or clouds and they also
will speak on on behalf of you and now
so you have really it gets even deeper
into an issue because you have the Quran
that's uncreated so obviously the
contents within the Quran also as you
said the contents of Allah speech is
uncreated so then the the contents of
the Quran that will those two suras that
will come out like flocks of birds and
intercede so flocks of birds is many
birds so the the the the chapters of the
Quran turn into many different beings
come as a conglomerate come as a
collective speak on your behalf you have
so many examples of the Quran being
conscious and cognitive and uncreated
speaking back to Allah you have so many
pluralities either within Allah or you
just have many gods this is the
issue okay so thank you for your
Protestant exegesis of Islam the Quran
the Sunnah so on and so forth but yet
again you still want to defer away from
my position right I don't care about
your Protestant view when it comes to
Sola scriptura and so on and so forth
for the fifth time now I'm going to ask
you do you want me to actually give you
the people who affirm my position or are
you going to continue with an ex that
has no basis and so on and so forth
because obviously the Hadith doesn't say
that first and foremost it's going to
come as a human it doesn't say anything
regarding the fact that the Quran itself
is true particular can I can I finish or
you sure right so
the Quran and your fasting is going to
intercede for you now if it's the case
you want to focus on the Quran can I
just ask you if it's the case that my
fasting is not a particular object or
thing that I'm holding in my hands
that's tangible and so on and so forth
can you can you please tell me how
exactly that's supposed to testify for
me since you want to get X for Jesus go
ahead oh no well no it's it's very
simple uh uh you know Allah has the
ability to uh give fasting create
fasting some type of corporeal form
where it can speak to you where it can
intercede for you where it can defend
you so you you ask you asking me break
this down and make it make sense for me
this is atachi this is not my problem
this is yours
EXC if youran why you interrup have you
ask me a question yeah I asked you a
question and now you're giving an exus
not only an exes but why are you why are
you interrupting me atachi yeah yeah I'm
I'm asking you to stay on
the I'm answering your question atachi
you you toally answer your question
because I ask you where in the Hadith
does it say that the fasting itself is
going to testify for you as a it says
that fasting and
sotion go I got you it says fasting and
the Quran will intercede for a man
fasting says oh my Lord I have kept him
away from his food and his passions by
day so accept my intercession for him
your fasting a tangible thing that
actually exists let me finish please
atachi right so is fasting a tangible
thing that actually ex I promise you I
will listen I promise yeah go ahead I
promise when it's your turn I'll listen
okay go ahead go ahead okay so according
to the Hadith however it happens well
let's just say Allah
we don't know how it happen go ahead the
the the fasting will have the ability to
speak to speak and say things and defend
you on the day of Resurrection not my
problem this is your problem so you have
the the the fasting and the Quran that
develop a Consciousness that's able to
defend you on the day of judgment the
problem here is is not with the fasting
because the fasting is not some uh
uncreated attribute of uh or uncreated
thing that has always existed but the
Quran is so you have the Quran that
exists within Allah's Essence that is
eternal and uncreated that now has a
Consciousness and is speaking to Allah
you now have a plurality of persons
within Allah's Essence
okay okay no problem so um God logic can
I can I ask you a basic question
regarding the Arabic right what does the
word Quran mean
recite okay and what is fast
uh fasting is when you abstain from
certain things would you agree that
these are two
actions sure okay are these two actions
particular things according to this
Hadith that I have done in my lifetime
that are attesting for me sure okay so
if it's the case that it's my actions
attesting for me does anything in the
Hadith imply that this thing is going to
now become a bodily form does it say
anything about a body or is that
something that you're just simply
implying based off I never I never said
body so number one I never said body I
said they will have the ability to speak
and now it's ask okay so I'm claring
said Remember You
St I let you finish I just don't want
you to build a point off no I'm not
strum ining the only one strum ining is
the one that's taking the Hadith out of
context right so did I did I say fast a
B for so again so I'm asking right
because you said that Allah can manifest
did I say that fting have a yes you did
said that Allah can make it so that it's
manifests as a corporeal sense I can
clip it and send you it so wait wait
wait wait wait so me me saying Corporal
doesn't Corporal literally Corporal I
never said that it it will have a
physical body though I never said it has
toysical body Corporal
form it's visible as some type of way
that it's G to speak
okay so we're going to look up the
definition of the word that you don't
know that you're using and we're going
to just see what it means okay so
Central can I get big screen please and
you say corporeal doesn't refer to the
fact that it's a body no what I was
saying is that I'm not talking about
that the that the fasting is going to
have a physical body I never said that I
said it's probably going to come into
into some Caporal form I said Allah who
knows okay but not a body that it's GNA
develop a Consciousness and be able to
speak but not a body go ahead go ahead
make your point word propal quite
literally means having a body right
that's the word that you just used right
corporeal it literally means having a
body right so I'm asking you again does
theith say anything about these two
particular actions which you agree their
actions does it say anything about them
coming in a material form yes or
no okay so can I answer you in full
without
interruption yeah please answer me
directly thank you so much so what I'm
saying is is I said Allah who knows how
the fasting is going to speak maybe it
will come into a Corporal body and you
corrected me thank you you corrected me
by Corporal lit some material form okay
so I I'm not too arrogant enough to be
like oh try to hold it no you you know
you're right on that so but I'm saying
Allah I'm not making this point like I
never said that oh the fasting is going
to have some Corporal form like it's
going to be like a definite is going to
have a physical body I that's that's not
the point I said I was giving that as an
option okay so but what my point is is
that fasting in the Quran will have will
develop a Consciousness okay whether
it's through a physical form the the the
Quran the Hadith is not specific on that
okay no problem now here's my question
to you because you talked about these
actions okay here's my question to you
right the Quran is the Quran in
action the recitation of the Quran yes
which is I I I I literally did not ask
that I asked
huh the Quran the recitation of the
Quran is an action I didn't ask that did
I ask that okay so it does not exist on
its own right words don't exp themselves
yeah so I'm answering you directly I'm
answering it's not an action you you
know how know how answer directly I'm
not asking about the recit let me ask
you this let me ask you this is there a
distinction between uh uh is there a
distinction of the recitation of the
Quran and the Quran
okay so the Quran in and of itself is a
recitation yes or no I'm I'm no you're
not answering the question is the
recitation of the Quran let me please is
the recitation of the Quran and the
Quran two distinct things okay the Quran
again for the third time the Quran is a
recitation it's not something that
exists on its own right it's not a book
like for example the book in and of
itself we don't Quran hold on we don't
call the book The Quran we call that the
mus yeah so the mus the one with ink and
letters and so on and so forth is not
what we consider the Quran Quran we
consider the Quran we consider a
recitation that's all it is so that's an
action it requires a bodily thing such
as myself or in the case of Allah it
requires Allah LA to enact a particular
form of speech did the Quran did the
Quran this recitation exist before it
was revealed to Muhammad
yes it did okay so the Quran this
recitation the Quran existed in and of
itself before it was recited by mankind
it was recited by Allah right yeah do
you know what the would you agree that
the Quran exists in the mother of the
book in the yeah the yeah very good so
it is actually in the mother of the book
very good so the Quran you know what the
mother of the book is so excuse me so
okay I'm asking just just to clarify do
you understand what is it's the mother
of the book what is that so hold on no
that's not the question I'm just asking
you what wait guys what does this have
to do with it has everything to do with
it it has everything to do with it watch
so the Quran exists in the mother of the
book before mankind ever recited it it
existed it was its own thing right when
Muhammad reced reced when muham reced
just clarify what do you mean own thing
when Muhammad recited he recited the
Quran correct correct so the Quran is
actually a thing that exists correct so
when we say when we
say okay so when we
say right we're referring to the
particular thing in of itself when we
refer to the Quran on its own we're
talking about the recitation of the
Revelation that Allah gave to jel who
gave it to Muhammad and so on and so
forth okay so again the hold on the
Quran in of itself is not something that
just exists on its
own is specifically something in which
Allah had transcribed it so again a
transcription is not the same thing as
the recitation in and of itself so
please if you if you will not STW men
and refer to things that are transcribed
because
ially four
times finish Amy from the mother of the
book yeah if you don't mind I am trying
to finish right okay again the Quran in
and of itself is a recitation when we
say the Quran is transcribed onto
particular things for
example for example the and so on and so
forth these are transcriptions of the
right the in and of itself is an action
can you please stick to that point no no
I I need you to stick to the point is is
when you say that the Quran when you say
that the Quran is in the mother of the
book it's in the mother of the book so
the Quran is actually a thing that's in
the mother of the book correct I just
need a yes or no on this transcription
again a transcription of something does
not refer to the fact that it's the
original thing is the Quran in the
mother of the book or not is the mother
of the book The Original source of it
I'm asking is the Quran in the mother of
the book yes or no okay even if I answer
yes it still does not change the fact it
still does not change the fact it's not
the original solic so why don't you try
to listen to the answer right because
I'm yes if it's yes I literally just did
okay thank you so that's all you got to
do just stop stop there okay is that the
SCE of so if the answer is yes the Quran
is in the mother of the book so is the
mother of the book The Original source
of the Quran we're not asking that
you're you're not I'm asking that I am
asking that because why can't you answer
the question before you ask another one
so beautiful so I'll explain to you why
I'm not answering your question I need
you to explain to me why you're not
answering I need you to answer the
question the mother of the book that you
keep referring to is not the original
source of the Quran when it's transcri
bro Central you're going to have to
moderate this or else I'm not going to
be able to actually answer fully you're
not answering nothing you have to
I'm okay so when it comes to this is not
the original source of the Quran the
original Source goes back to the Creator
who recited it again it being a
recitation it is an action okay when the
Creator for example would transcribe it
onto when the creation transcribes it
into the and so on and so forth this
does not change the original form of the
Quran being a actual recitation that's
not that's not how this works right a
transcription does not take away from
the original attribute of it being a
recitation of it being speech can you
please are you done are you done I thank
you so much so since you're unwilling
since you're unwilling to actually
answer my question I'll help you when
you say that the Quran is just a
recitation it's just the action of
reciting that that's it it's just the
action of reciting it's not an actual
book it's not an actual book even though
the Quran says that it's an actual book
this is the book reveal did I say that
yes you did you said this no no I didn't
I said
original wait wait stop please stop my
God you literally said the Quran is not
a book it's a recitation it's an action
you literally said that so now that I
got you I refer to that I was talking
about the tough right again I'm talking
about the book very simple is the B
talking about the book that you hold in
your hands or is also something that's
transcribed is being the original SCE of
the book oh my God okay the original
source of it is a recitation it being
written down into the book okay it being
written down into a book form the way
that we understand a book today is not
the original source of it so is it a
book yes or no it is one of the revealed
books of Allah
which was originally so it's a book
Thank you so the Quran is a book that's
revealed from Allah thank you so much
Itachi so the Quran is a book that's
revealed how was ited on hold on excuse
so how was it revealed thank you for
finally answering after the marathon so
hold on a second please hold on a second
please
soan excuse me excuse me excuse
me I'll just thank you so much so this
is where you got caught you got caught
when you just tried to simplify or
oversimplify the Quran as simply being
an action you said out of your own mouth
that it's not a book you said that so
you went against your Quran but now
you're acknowledging that the Quran is a
book it's one of Allah's revealed books
very good so now when the Hadith over
here says fasting will intercede for you
and also the Quran will intercede for
you not you not your action not what
you're doing the Quran the revealed book
of Allah is going to intercede for you
on your behalf and guess what the
revealed book of Allah the Quran is
uncreated it's Eternal and it's within
Allah's Essence that develops a
Consciousness that's able to defend you
and talk back to Allah you have Itachi a
plurality of persons within your Allah
toed destroyed when we say that it is
from the speech of and that this is the
original source of it meaning what is
this an action or is this a book that
you hold in your hands do you hold
somebody's speech in your
hands uh Allah's speech is the Quran
that he declares declares is a book that
he revealed
right okay can you can you answer my
question no I am answering you I'm
answering you through the question no no
you're actually you're not there you
like to do so can you hold somebody
speech in your hands like like you like
to do right so can you hold some some
speech in your hands no no you can't
okay beautiful so is the Quran can you
hold someone's speech in a book okay is
the Quran a
speech thean is a speak and it's a book
okay which book one of Allah's revealed
books according to you okay is this the
book the book that we hold in our hands
today uh you tell me no absolutely not
right because I already clarified for
you the fact the most again don't
interrupt me right so the mus is not
what we refer to being the Quran did I
not say this already like three times
before yeah is the Quran a book that
exist is that the book that we hold
today yes or
noit
question respond a point I'm responding
now you just made a point respond answer
my question so the Quran so you so you
agree though that the Quran because you
you already affirmed this that the Quran
is one of Allah's revealed books I'm
using your own words so if the Quran is
one of Allah's revealed books now
whether you're now you're saying well
well it's not a book in which we
understand a book to be today like a
physical you know physical Musa fine no
problem but it's some type of book right
that Allah says is a book that he
revealed now this book within itself
intercedes for you speaks on your behalf
is
uncreated and is within the essence of
Allah there's no way around it asking
these other little Rabbit Trail
questions doesn't help the fact that t
he you just destroyed it right so once
again straw maning right so again can
you answer my question directly is
speech something that you can hold in
your hands I already answered this why
are you asking it again yeah because you
don't want to actually answer it you
keep jumping around asking 10 other
things
Destro so is speech something that you
hold in your hands I'll do it again
speech is not something that you can
physically okay beautiful is the Quran a
speech Yes and a book okay which book
one of of Allah you we doing this which
one
is what's that is it the or is
it what exactly are you asking I know
you're talking about the of the book
when we're talking about when we say
that the what we hold in our hands today
is that what we use to refer to the
Quran or are we referring to the speech
of Allah subhana tala that's a that's
one of Allah's books that's revealed
that's up there not the question I asked
you yeah it is the question you asked
actually no it's not I asked you it the
mus or is it the speech that we refer to
in terms of a again again you said you
said that the Quran is not the physical
books that you have here on Earth you
say so but you affirmed that the Quran
is one of Allah's revealed books that is
basically it's immaterial it's not
something you can hold and touch and
feel it's immaterial so he has a the
Quran is an immaterial book right that
is the speech of Allah some of the
speech not entirely some of Allah's
speech an immaterial book that exists
within the mother of the book that is
with Allah that will also intercede for
you and speak on your
behalf are you
done can I can I get an answer to my
question now instead of are you serious
yes I am serious because you keep
referring to something I'm not asking
you atachi I I don't know how many times
you want to do this right because you
don't want to answer the question like I
can be very persistent when it comes to
getting a question answered if you don't
want to answer it you could just say so
right I could give you the answer if
you'd like you you want to do this again
hold let me check if my Salmon's like
done because I cooked you let me cook my
salmon um so yeah I I think that uh I
think that this was pretty clear this is
why uh I think everything that's been
said has been said um you went back and
forth on this this is what we got on a
little summary uh that the Quran is uh
is Allah's is some of Allah's uncreated
speech so Allah speech speech has Parts
the Quran is not entirely Allah speech
it's some of Allah speech not entirely
so it's made up of parts so uh logical
problem of the attributes of Allah I
guess we can come up with this the LPA
logical problem of
attributes oh my God
[Music]
logic
oh